yeah welcome to this video I play
involving again yeah play this guy often
and I always have black and seems ok
let's try something else playing this
wiki line it's not that bad ok up to
five yeah do I just take off put it to
somewhere bag and he has to check
possibly and taking on at five okay i'm
taking play it simple
you have to go see five at some point
okay it looks very shaky this this kind
of configuration 55 at the NTS bishop
age seven okay i play plane or remove
them
Oh is really doing something that's
quite unlike him so b6 and a five or or
a five immediately okay let's start with
that and then 85 taking this this pawn
chain yeah I try to Pam have to play
quickly against him and have this slight
history there of time losses in the room
where is shuffling around and winning on
time so not not thinking try to not
think too long if if it doesn't feel so
necessary so we 5m
somes g6 a move that makes sense
probably not
my rook c8 runs like it goes right into
this pin now that's it's probably not a
good idea though I don't really see what
he's doing them against her or with it
against it is wrong wrong phrase hmm
yeah it looks a bit better for what
looks a bit better for him do I play it
I can try Mac I thought if for maybe but
does it help much okay maybe I should
still kick him okay now i'm sure g7 is
not doing any good
yeah yeah I played that well that's just
good for him it's got good pressure
there with the bishops
Jim not very nice maybe just queen bee
three and something Quincy one yeah
again that was strong it really was
strong yep I'm here plus ugly position
ugly position that was one idea with
this age five move but definitely in
trouble Queen d2 maybe simply
96 yeah i feeli probably had something
better even but it still looks quite
awful it's quite an awful position yeah
cannot cannot not really having many
attractive possibility same Queen have 8
night f5 sitting
you
rook e8 you can take play night b7 well
oh is this plenty night f5
yeah it's just bad bed as in Las Vegas
time morning thank you I definitely had
better stetter things but
yeah he definitely had better things I'm
not sure what this is now but I had I
had more trouble they were more trouble
with other continuations pretty sure
them rook t7 is a big issue I thought
wow winning the spinner would do a
windows peace now I'd be a nice comeback
from this completely lost position since
I wouldn't appease him
check knight Knight a5 would be nice to
get in but I don't don't really seem to
manage okay
Queen he I'm checking for night at five
again
check g35 could Roxy for something like
that should be you should be enough
check check night somewhere 94 no I'm
blundering the night there whoops i can
actually do this Queen f6 is made check
made on g3 or whatever two mates Queen
g3 or not g3 made white resume how I
small survived this he totally outplayed
me here not only hits the other way
around like I i play I get an advantage
but he does the time thing but he he
crushed me and somehow some more did not
did not finish me off yeah so I was
thinking night at five here we went here
every day I mean like here what am I
playing really hey I just didn't know
what to move so I just I just played
lately for I mean okay and he I just
loool I'm just losing i mean i ever ever
do that check he wins the rook and jim
just an exchange that I'm just totally
lost Jim Jim somehow the game continues
Knight takes e4 now is strong but after
this I'm all of a sudden clearly back
into the game yeah maybe he has to do
something like that trying to hold this
position that's still pretty solid
and here after this he just loses loses
the piece amazing yeah very very lucky
win but they have my fair share of
strange losses against this guy so might
might give me a break here and there
okay well thanks for watching